du hast gewonnen was gemacht und was
gewonnen ich habe ein sehr gutes spiel
hallöchen meine lieben freunde herzlich
willkommen zu einem neuen multiplayer
online pvp gaming mode namens zusammen
mit um gespielt und irgendwie anderen
leuten die uns erkennen
halo hat sich gelegt die namen sind der
zug schlägt was bei mir grad nicht aber
ich erkläre mir ganz kurz mails so wie
ich das bisher verstand es ist ein
server der die ip ist eu.com in der
beschreibung auf jeden fall und dort das
verschiedene spielmodi wie zum beispiel
die das mesh was ihr gleich sehen werdet
da gibt es auch meinen sie also mein set
dann gibt es dort irgendwie andere pvp
sachen also alle möglichen sachen auf
einem server zusammengefasst und dieses
match ist halt auch noch funktioniert so
iris und da hinten irgendwo wenn ihr
schweigen geld wollte das nur ganz kurz
es bauen da hinten oder so laufen hier
bleiben und dann gibt es hier so ein
paar auswahlmöglichkeiten von
verschiedenen netzen richtig aber das
ist halt der premium apps und es gibt
public maps und wir sind beide nur
public member
er spielt auf jeden fall jeder spielt
gegen jeden
das heißt jeder kann hier jeden töten
und angreifen und es gibt einen
doppelsprung hinweg so aus batterie
erklären reste spieltrieb auf atrium
weil ich doch sonst komme ich ins spiel
android welches atrium ja da auf atrium
jedes zweite von von links also der
stand auf atrium du weißt schon ja gut
er weist mich ganz so einfach ist es
voll okay ist jetzt hier weiter und
warten dort das jetzt noch 14 56
sekunden
hier steht neun minuten nein minuten
geht die ganze runde
bis hier steht 9live 5 live running ach
ich bin ja ich weiß
das sind menschen die schon spielen die
sache okay ich habe also es sind halt
jeder gegen jeden höchstens drei bis
acht leuten ja und noch die areale
anspringe und wenn man doppelsprung und
shift gedrückt da macht man eben dieser
tag aber wie funktioniert bei mir nicht
so gut
oder hat alles geklappt bei mir du musst
immer warten die green lässt komplett
aufgefüllt ist unter den herzen jetzt
nicht da musste warten mich auch
schröders und dann musst du doppel sport
einem schiff jetzt gerade mir
dazu kommt bestimmt anders war das bei
einer band
ich weiß jetzt was ich wissen dass egal
jedenfalls macht man eben diesen sprung
das ist bei mir ist es die gleichen test
aufgefallen
8.11 uhr anderes ja ich hab immer bei
strg unten abtrennen hätte ich doch auch
nein du bist weißt du was ich konnte ja
die shift-taste entdeckt doppelspur mit
einer ach so ja warte guckt dann kann
ich das jetzt auch machen gucke ich
dachte hier spielt jeder gegen jeden um
muss ich halt ihn tötet man nachher
dreileben aber dass er gleich euch
einfach mal in game warte da in lobby
auch das erste mal dass erste priorität
sein public dann macht das reisen wo es
eis als public maps kennt doch gar nicht
ist die fünfte total okay du bist dran
und wir haben gleich unten links nur
drei herzen aber das ist nicht unser
leben sondern unser leben ist das level
was wir haben
oller desto höher das leben geht desto
mehr desto höher ist die
wahrscheinlichkeit dass wir ihnen die
runterfallen oder so weiter fliegen wir
und wenn wir dreimal von der mep runter
gefallen sind dann sind komplett raus
dort könnten tage dauern
jetzt weiß ich glaube ich glaube die
maps ich weiß warum die lässt es ist mit
nur 1 scheuen und sonst nichts das heißt
du okay so schlecht ist sie gar nicht
aber du rutscht die ganze okay also der
ford cortina
ich bin vorsichtig hinter dem deutlich
dass diese leute ich versuche ich ein
bisschen zu schützen reicht ich bin ganz
körper emissionsschutz ist bester
schütze irgendwo gibt die möchtest du
bist du jetzt eigentlich gehen wir
weiter nach oben weil hier unten ist
unsicher ich bin schon einmal runter
gefallen wie ihr seht der doppelsprung
bei mir manchmal hauptträger geschrieben
kindheit luca und wie man wollte meine
sonne sein logo
da das video sieht nein nein ich bin
schon wieder runter gefallen
auch simon ihr sehr ihr seht schon die
man das empfand komplett
ich hätte euch das mal ganz gesagt ich
habe jetzt zwei da unten nicht schaden
dass es sehr sehr gering sei es dass
mich einer schlägt nicht unter fall ist
nicht so wahrscheinlich
und ich habe überall science in der hand
hier so ganz kurz zum zweiten mal nur
einen slot frei insgesamt weiterhin ist
eine komische insel das andere
merkwürdig ich bin ich bin ein verdammt
ich bin ich bin auch noch einmal runter
gefallen ist aktiv an ich wollte ich das
einkehren und jetzt habe ich dort unten
zb noch zwei herzen
das liegt daran das liegt daran dass
nein bleibt doch stehen woran liegt das
das liegt daran dass hatte ich möchte
den typen der eben immer schlank ich bin
schon raus allerdings an mir fest was
ist das der ist aus der u-haft es geht
angeblich weiß nicht wann ich bin sehr
schlechten im camp aber du vielleicht
gewinnst du sogar noch conny du das ist
nicht fair die doppel spruch ich hab
nämlich park doppelsprung gefällt und
bin dann selber aber jetzt habe ich auch
noch ein herz das heißt oder kommt ein
und versucht mich zu angeln erst weiter
gefallen jawohl ich hoffe dass gewonnen
ein gegner hast du noch steht ihnen auf
die schale auf der apfelschorle der
hammer gefallen
falls ich unter aus einer dass er
richtig ärgerlich ich glaube mich du
bist nicht sind noch drei leute im spiel
okay da der tat nicht so gut an
ja okay jetzt geht es also ich hab da
ist noch ein herz hat den abnehmen aber
dass auch noch einen gegner
das noch ein gegner hab ich einfach nur
noch ein leben erst runter gefallen es
runter gefallen er wehrt er noch etwas
gewonnen was gemacht und was gewonnen
ich habe einige sehr gut in dem spiel
gewinnen also leute das ist das
spielprinzip also ich habe jetzt noch
ein herz das heißt ich hätte jetzt nur
noch ein leben gehabt das hätte mich
noch ein
runterschubsen können dann wäre ich auch
raus gewesen deswegen reichte am ende
auch ein bisschen mehr defensiv und das
gewissen gehabt habe bin ich jetzt auch
nicht so und die offensive schreiben wir
alle davon hat lacht na gut lass mal auf
nur noch hinten dranhängen bis jetzt
erstmal so als tutorial erklärung und
fragen ob du doch ich glaub ich lasse es
sogar erst mal so das passt eigentlich
also erst mal ne runde wie gefällt euch
das euch das vielleicht mal öfters
machen weil das kann man auch so
zwischen ich einfach mal offen lassen
nicht dass jeder gegen jeden noch nicht
so viel am ende dass man einfach random
gekillt wird die wollen alle die
aufnahme auch niedlich kingking die den
grüße ich jetzt ein grüß ich jetzt king
of swing klingt nein klingt ach so ich
kann ich lesen ok fixgehalt ich bin ja
auch gleich sehen die grüße ich auch
koks player kriegen sie aus und begrüßte
mich auch alle habe ich gerade ungestüm
gespielt achso genommen hier noch rover
3 conti sei ruhig will screenshot okay
ich stelle mich jetzt hier kannst einen
krieg mit mehr machen ja also dafür dass
er einfach alles gerockt hat hier das
gilt gibt einfach einen daumen hoch wenn
euch das gefällt wenn ihr mehr wollte
und so weiter wer auf jeden fall cool
macht mir auf jeden fall spaß smash muss
mit ein bisschen rein arbeiten aber es
war am anfang von problemen will auch so
ich hab richtig hält eingespielt ist
einfach richtung ungeduld dumm gespielt
hallo allemal bitte dumm gespielt in die
kommentare schreiben
immer noch seien alle dumm gespielt
das gleich zweimal ok ok dann lasst es
lastet lieber erscheint wer alle die das
die kommentare schreiben
welche marken und seine mutter sagt hey
mama die armee sind dann grüßt euch
allen ein video die das sind kommt
anschreiben auf jeden fall
na gut meine freunde dann würd ich sagen
sie uns eventuell bei einer weiteren
runde / das war bei mir die erste und
ciao